cette guerre mettant présence la
sécurité sociale et la confédération des
syndicats médicaux français qui regroupe
70 % des médecins syndicats la
confédération refuse d'appliquer les
nouveaux tarifs des honoraires médicaux
fixé par la sécurité sociale dans le
cadre de la convention nationale signée
en 1971
ces nouveaux tarifs entraîne une
augmentation de 2 francs pour les
visites et consultations de généralistes
et de spécialistes
la confédération estime cette hausse des
barèmes insuffisante et elle demande à
tous ses adhérents d'appliquer son
propre barème d aujourd'hui c'est à dire
une augmentation de 2 francs pour les
consultations de médecine générale et de
3 francs pour les visites ou
consultations de spécialistes mais cette
rupture entre la sécurité sociale et la
confédération des syndicats médicaux
français représente beaucoup plus qu'une
simple augmentation
c'est toute la politique médicale
française que voudrait remettre en cause
la confédération leur revendication
principale donnée aux médecins libéraux
l'esprit d'entreprise et assurer aux
médecins salariés les garanties
nécessaires
les barèmes officiels de la caisse de
sécurité sociale seront applicables au
1er janvier 75 en attendant les malades
qui consulteront des médecins adhérents
la confédération des syndicats médicaux
français ne seront remboursés que sur la
base des tarifs de la caisse nationale
c'est à dire en dessous de ce qu'ils
auront réellement payé pour ces médecins
réfractaires
l'enjeu est important il risque de ne
plus être conventionnée ce qui porterait
un grave préjudice à la médecine
française et aux assurés sociaux
pour sa part la fédération des médecins
de france a décidé d'accepter les
propositions de la sécurité sociale